- C'est la décennie
de la dernière chance.
Québec solidaire passe en mode
climat avec sa vision 2030.
- C'est le plan
le plus ambitieux.
- Une révolution du transport
en commun qui comprend
et de Québec Bus pour relier
toutes les villes du Québec.
L'interdiction de vendre
des voitures à essence serait
devancée à 2030 au lieu de 2035.
En plus d'imposer une taxe
de 15 % sur les véhicules
polluants, comme l
dès l'an prochain.
- Je dirais que c'est
un très bon plan de lutte
les changements climatiques.
- Mais q similarités
entre le plan du Parti québécois
et celui de Québec de Québec de.
firme de modélisation.
Paul Saint-Pierre Plamondon
s'attaque donc maintenant
à la CAQ.
chef du Parti québécois
- Le vrai sujet, c'est pas tant
qu'on a besoin de collaboration
sur des choses qui, en fait,
sont dites de manière trè
côté, quand on voit des partis
qui font des déclarations commee
"Lâchez-moi avec les GES".C'estr
dans quelle époque ils vivent.
PIERRE-OLIVIER PINEAU, Chaire de
gestion du secteur de l'énergie
- Ils ciblent les éléments
décarbonation du secteur
du transport. Et tout comme
le Parti québécois, Québec
solidaire dans le secteur
des bâtiments cible la cotation
- Bâtiments plus
écoénergeilleure
gestion des déchets, le plan
c solidaire prévoit
aussi de serrer la vis
aux grands pollueurs.
Le marchne sera
ajusté à la nouvelle cible
de réduction, soit 55 %
- Nous, on va donnon va donnon x
aux gens qui n'en ont pas. Et
aux gens qui abusent, les grands
romènent en jet privé,
oui, avec ces gens-là,
- Québec assure que
personne ne perdra son emploi
lors de cette transition verte,
qui doitpremier mapremier mapre,
dont 29 milliards uniquement
pour le transport collectif.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-C